The Merc with a Mouth may be in for a Marvel-sized
reality check if or, more realistically, when
he joins the MCU.
After enjoying two refreshingly batty films
with Deadpool 1 & 2, audiences worldwide have
been wondering what's coming next.
Fans of the no-holds-barred superhero franchise
were initially over the moon when star Ryan
Reynolds recently announced that the potty-mouthed
hero would soon be making his MCU debut.
With the tentatively titled Deadpool 3 now
officially in production under the Marvel
Studios shingle by way of its parent company
Disney it seems MCU mastermind Kevin Feige
could be eyeing major changes for the Deadpool
franchise.
The latest little nugget of MCU rumor madness
comes via the not-super-reliable rumor-mongers
over at We Got This Covered, who are reporting
an alleged emphasis on "alleged" Marvel insider's
claims that Feige is looking to replace some
key creatives behind the Deadpool franchise.
Don't worry, he's apparently not looking to
push Ryan Reynolds out of the picture and
recast the role of Wade Wilson but according
to WGTC, Feige is looking to take some creative
control out of Reynolds' hands.
As a reminder, Reynolds has served as producer
and a key creative force behind both Deadpool
and Deadpool 2, hand-picking director David
Leitch for the sequel and even earning a writing
credit for his work on that film.
It's been speculated that Reynolds was pushing
to bring the creative team behind Deadpool
2 back for the upcoming sequel, including
his co-writers Rhett Reese and Paul Wernick.
Feige, according to the rumor, isn't sold
on bringing Leitch back to helm Deadpool 3
and is reportedly keen on bringing Ant-Man
and the Wasp scribes Chris Mckenna and Eric
Sommers on board to fully Marvel-ize the sequel.
Way to pull the rug out from under these folks,
Marvel!
"Hah!
Fake laugh… hiding real pain."
As for what those supposed changes could mean
for Deadpool 3, it's possible that the Merc
we've come to know and love over the course
of the first two deliriously crass Deadpool
movies may be toned way, way down.
Of course, that may not be entirely a bad
thing.
While the first two Deadpool movies have served
as a welcome departure from the increasingly
homogenized realm of superhero cinema, even
the characters' most ardent fans would likely
admit the winking meta schtick was wearing
a little thin by the end of Deadpool 2.
Still, that wickedly self-aware approach has
spawned a hyper-specific style in the movies,
and it's sort of impossible to imagine what
Deadpool 3 might look like without it.
"You might wanna look away for this.
Now, this little piggy went to — "
Deadpool remains a singular voice in the Marvel
canon, so much so that a stark change in tone
might leave his new flick all but unrecognizable
from its cinematic brethren, not to mention
the comics.
To date, the decision by Reynolds and the
Deadpool creatives to lean headlong into the
comics' special brand of wacky is a big part
of what has set the franchise apart from every
other superhero story out there.
If Team Marvel is indeed looking to shake
things up, the changes might be to the detriment
of Deadpool 3.
However, as we previously mentioned, WGTC's
report is in no way confirmed, and it may
in fact all be a bunch of hot air let's face
it: WGTC isn't exactly known for their pinpoint
accuracy.
Plus, Feige is a pretty smart guy, and changing
or eliminating everything that makes the Deadpool
franchise unique doesn't exactly sound like
his style.
Regardless of whether a change in direction
is in the cards, it does appear that a good
deal of the previous flicks' cast may be back
for Deadpool 3 though some fan faves might
not be.
TJ Miller, who appeared as Wilson's buddy
Weasel in the first two films, and Brianna
Hildebrand, who portrayed the wonderfully
surly Negasonic Teenage Warhead, are both
still on the fence.
WGTC has reported that Hildebrand may not
return but, again, their reports should be
taken with a grain of salt and according to
CBR, Miller is iffy on the prospect of reprising
his role, though he is under contract.
"Just once, I'm gonna find a planet of people
that are worse than me at everything.
A whole bunch of functional idiots.
I'm gonna go there, and I'm gonna be their
Superman."
"...Isn't that Canada?"
Marvel is apparently eager to bring two of
Deadpool 2's standouts back for the new film,
however: ScreenRant reports that Zazie Beetz
has a three-picture deal and is set to return
as Domino, and Josh Brolin has a similar deal
that should ensure that he'll reprise the
role of Cable at least another time or two
according to SlashFilm.
With those heavy hitters seemingly on board
for Deadpool 3, it seems even more likely
Kevin Feige and Marvel will stay the course,
weaving the R-rated, jaw-droppingly vulgar
Wade Wilson we all know and love into the
MCU fabric.
This is our sincere hope because without his
potty mouth, is Deadpool even Deadpool at
all?
We think not.
We'll be filling you in on all the Deadpool
3 news that's fit to report as soon as it
becomes available.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.